our david pakman show subreddit
continues to grow nearly 5,000 of our
viewers and listeners now we're
regularly participating there you can
find it at david pakman.com slash read
it I was browsing the subreddit this
morning found some interesting
discussions that I wanted to share with
you starting with no less than a
discussion about what we can actually
expect to happen what seems more like
when rather than if net neutrality is
repealed and it's a very interesting
discussion of okay we hear the
generalities about the dangers of a net
neutrality repeal but what could the
internet actually be like if and when
that takes place good discussion also
from our reddit discussion forum a
correction which is an absolutely
accurate one I gave an incorrect example
of how net neutrality could impact
Netflix by talking about Time Warner as
the owner of Time Warner Cable and thus
the owner of HBO and as it actually
stands Time Warner Cable and Time Warner
the parent company did separate did
separate some time ago so the I should
have picked other examples for that
analogy or that explanation so I stand
corrected on the specifics but the exact
there are numerous other examples that
are very similar one of them should have
changed their name to avoid confusion to
begin with I know yeah but a lot of
brand loyalty associated but mostly
negative people hate their cable
companies but at least brand recognition
I guess we would call it also from the
reddit discussion forum what do you
think Trump will where do you think
Trump will spend his post president life
I'm more interested in what Trump will
do after he's no longer President of the
United States like will it be enough to
just go back and sit in his office with
his fake Time magazine covers making
different deals for building real estate
by hiring undocumented immigrants in the
entire thing like will that satisfy him
after being president I don't know are
we talking about the recreation hour you
get in jail you know if Donald Trump
ever did go to jail or prison or
whatever I don't assume he would be
particularly active during his hour in
the exercise yard duh don't take my word
for it just look at the guy on the golf
course okay also from our reddit
discussion forum how do you feel about
David's use of
bate titles this is a fun for people who
listen to the podcast or watch the show
on TV you aren't aware of the quite
frankly pretty clever titles that we
come up with for our YouTube videos and
I reject the idea of the term clickbait
we come up with titles that reflect the
content of the video but are as
interesting as possible right why would
we pick titles that won't make people
want to watch the clip so yes we
deliberately pick the titles that we
think will get the most attention for
the video with the understanding that it
has to reflect the subject matter of the
video if that's clickbait then call me
clickbait johnny now i would recommend
your interview of sargon of akkad on the
desk - that was quite a discussion
absolutely or not was it a takedown or
did we todo we did talk about clickbait
that's right yeah years ago during the
gamergate days and lastly what's up with
the website why is the david pakman show
website only showing the shows from last
week etc etc a number of questions and
comments about what the hell happened to
the David Pakman show website over the
last couple of days I will address that
in the next segment you can join us on
reddit at david pakman.com slash our EDD
IT